START BY MAKING A SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
RULES COMMITTEE OF HEARD THIS
BEFORE- SO THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SO LET ME GO OVER THE TECHNICAL
SIDE OF THINGS FOR THE DAY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
HAS MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. BOB CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND THE SAFETY OF
THE PUBLIC OUR EMPLOYEES.
TODAY'S HEARING IS BEING HELD
HERE IN OUR CAPITAL. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE. SERVICE
FOR OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN. AND IT'S GOOD
WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN FIVE ZERO TWO
ZERO ONE THREE. AGAIN. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN FIVE ZERO TWO
ZERO ONE THREE. WHEN WE DO MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUSIC
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO THE
NEW ONLINE TOOLS. SO PLEASE
AGAIN BE PATIENT SO EVERYBODY
CAN BE HEARD AND WE CAN TAKE
THE COMMENT. ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OUR STENOGRAPHER I'M GONNA ASK
ALL SPEAKERS AND PEOPLE WILL BE
DOING A REALLY GREAT JOB OF
THIS. TO SPEAKS SLOWLY. ARE AND
IT CLEARLY AND- SO THAT SHOULD
BE ABLE TO GET YOUR YOUR NAME
AND WHO YOU REPRESENT AND YOUR
TESTIMONY. SO BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND SO AS A
REMEMBER TO MY COLLEAGUES WILL
NEED TO TURN ON OUR MICROPHONES
FOR THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY
TIME THAT WE VOTE. AND
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FAITH HERE IT'S HERE
MINING PEER LEARNING HERE ROTH-
ROTH HERE WILK PRESIDENT WILK
PRESENT ATKINS HERE I CAN SEE
HERE OKAY- WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
DO ON OUR AGENDA IF POSSIBLE IS
TAKE NUMBER TWO WHICH IS THE
REFERRAL OF BILLS TO COMMITTEES.
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION SO
MOVED THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BATES. BATES AYE MINING.
MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH AYE WILK
BY WILL AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS
AYE THANK YOU FIVE ZERO AND- WE
HAVE DISPENSED WITH ITEM NUMBER
TWO WE WILL NOW GO TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR AND WE'RE GONNA START
WITH MS RANDA L. CRAFT TO IS
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL OF THE
INDEPENDENT OFFICES OF ALL AND
INVEST. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION WELCOME I SEE
YOU ON THE SCREEN WONDERFUL SO-
WHAT WE TYPICALLY DO IS CRAFT
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT MIGHT
BE THERE WITH YOU THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THANK. AND THEN
ANY OPENING COMMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE AND THEN WE WILL COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND GO RIGHT
TO MEMBER COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SO WITH THAT I'LL
TURN. IT OVER TO YOU AND AGAIN
SAY WELCOME. THANK YOU-
GREETINGS GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS- BEFORE I
GET STARTED I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND HIS
STAFF FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MY FAMILY WHO HAS BEEN
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF MY CAREER
ASPIRATIONS. ALWAYS THERE FOR
ME AS WELL AS THE IDEAL I STAFF
WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF SINCE MY
APPOINTMENT. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK EACH OF YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE CONFIRMATION OF
MY APPOINTMENT AS INSPECTOR
GENERAL OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
CALTRANS. I KNOW YOU HAVE MY
RESUME BEFORE USE SO I WILL BE
BRIEF AND FOCUS ON LAND
INTERESTED IN THIS POSITION. I
HAVE A DEGREE IN MANAGEMENT
FROM SAINT MARY'S COLLEGE OF.
CALIFORNIA I HAVE MORE THAN
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF STATE
SERVICE WITHIN TRANSPORTATION
MOST OF THAT TIME HAS BEEN
SPENT IN A LEADERSHIP CAPACITY.
WITH INCREASING
RESPONSIBILITIES OVER THE
YEARS. INCLUDING MY PREVIOUS
POSITION AS DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF TRAFFIC SAFETY WHERE
I ADMINISTERED A NEARLY NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS TRAFFIC SAFETY
GRANT PROGRAM. IN THIS CAPACITY
THE OFFICE THE TRAFFIC SAFETY
IS ALREADY EVERY THREE YEARS BY
THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION SO I FEEL
LIKE I HAVE. A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE TO BE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE TABLE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEING ABLE TO SEE CLEAR AND
CONCISE INFORMATION THAT IS
USEFUL AND PROVIDES THE KIND OF
FEEDBACK IS NECESSARY FOR YOU
TO MAKE CORRECTIVE ACTION TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION. IF NECESSARY.
WALGREENS GRAVITATED TO
POSITIONS WHERE I COULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FROM LEADING TEAMS
ESTABLISHED TO STREAMLINE
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS. AS WELL AS
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
OPPORTUNITY. AFTER BEING ALONG
WITH STRONG LEADERSHIP SKILLS
THAT I BELIEVE ARE CRITICAL TO
THE SUCCESS OF THIS POSITION.
SB ONE EMPATHIZES
ACCOUNTABILITY IN
TRANSPORTATION IN TRANSPARENCY
FOR THE TIME BEING GRAMS
CREATED BY THE LEGISLATION.
SPECIFICALLY THE INDEPENDENT
OFFICE EDUCATION WAS CREATED TO
ENSURE THAT CALTRANS AN
EXTERNAL IN ENTITIES WHO
RECEIVED STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING ARE USING THOSE FOR THE-
SHE IN AN EFFECTIVE. EFFICIENT
AND COST EFFICIENT MANNER. IT
IS USED IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
THIS IS HOW WE MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. WE MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BY ISSUING
OUTSTANDING PRODUCTS THAT ARE
TIMELY. ACTIVE BALANCED IN
PRESENTED IN SUCH A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO ACT ON INFORMATION TO
BAIT. WE CAN ACTIVELY IDENTIFY
REPORT BEST PRACTICES.
OPPORTUNITIES TO STRENGTHEN
INTERNAL CONTROLS WE CAN ADD
VALUE IN PROVIDE INFORMATION TO
IMPROVE PERFORMANCE OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCY AND COST REDUCTIONS
AS WELL AS ENHANCE DECISION
MAKING THAT PROMOTES
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN CLOSING
ACCOUNTABILITY IS KEY TO
MAINTAINING PUBLIC TRUST. FOUR
GUIDING PRINCIPLES OF THE
INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF AUDITS
AND INVESTIGATIONS. INDEPENDENT
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY AND
EXCELLENT WE CAN FOSTER AND
PROMOTE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
INTEGRITY MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS CRAFT I THINK I'M GONNA
LOOK. IN THIS DIRECTION AND
START WITH SENATOR MINING. WELL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
CONGRATULATIONS INSPECTOR
GENERAL THAT HAS A NICE RING TO
IT DOESN'T IT- WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE YOU HAVE. MANY
YEARS OF SERVICE TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU. FOR THAT SERVICE-
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT WE
HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY I THINK ONE THING
THAT WOULD PERHAPS BE OF
INTEREST. TO OUR PANEL IN THE
PUBLIC- ALTHOUGH I KNOW IT MAY
GET TOO TECHNICAL TOO FAST BUT-
PART OF THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE OFFICES AS I UNDERSTAND IT
WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE. AND
OVER FIVE BILLION A YEAR
ANTICIPATED FOR ROAD REPAIR
ROAD MAINTENANCE OTHER FORMS OF
TRANSPORTATION DEVELOPMENT- IS
FOR YOUR OFFICE TO. ALSO LOOK
AT THE FISSION SEES SAVINGS AND
EFFICIENCIES. IN ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WE TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY IS HOW- WITHIN
EXISTING PROGRAMS WHERE THERE'S
AN ASPIRATION FOR SAVINGS. HOW
DO WE MOVING FORWARD DETERMINE
IF WE'RE GETTING BETTER AT THAT
OR MAYBE JUST SHARE THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN HOW YOU
MEASURE OF EFFICIENCY VERSUS
SAVINGS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
THAT QUESTION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME YESTERDAY AND I
APPRECIATED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU. SO I THINK IT BE
HELPFUL IF I KIND THEY WOULD
DESCRIBE. HELLO MY HOT OFFICE
INVOLVED WITH EACH EFFICIENCY.
AND THIS MY OFFICE REVIEWS THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
PROCESSES AND METHODOLOGIES
USED BY CALTRANS. COURT
REPORTING SERVICE. SO THESE
THESE ARE INDUSTRY STANDARDS
USED BY MANY DOT'S THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY AND REQUIRE
SUPPORTING DOCUMENTATION TO BE
THERE EVERY STEP. OF THE
PROJECT. ANY END THESE ARE THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WE USE AND TO
REVIEW IN ORDER TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE MET THE RECORDED SAVINGS
THAT THEY HAVE INDICATED AND IT
IS DURING THIS PROCESS THAT WE
BELIEVE IS HELPFUL IN MAKING
SURE THAT THEY ARE HAVING THE
PERFORMANCE IN THE OUTCOMES
THAT IS EXPECTED OF SH BACKED
IT WAS THROUGH THIS PROCESS
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
IN THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
EFFICIENCY REPORT. THAT THERE
WAS AN OVER REPORTING IN SO WE
ARE CONFIDENT ABOUT THE PROCESS
THAT WE USE. IN ORDER TO REVIEW.
THE EFFICIENCY AND THE
METHODOLOGY THAT IS USED BY
CALTRANS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
XIN IN IT WAS WITH REFERENCE TO
THAT EARLIER REPORT THAT YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU HELPED ME TO
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE IN IN
HOW YEAR OFFICE IS EQUIPPED TO
IDENTIFY AN OVER REPORTING. OF
A SAVINGS SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
IN- AGAIN I THOROUGHLY ENJOYED
OUR CONVERSATION YESTERDAY I
DON'T HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS
TODAY- BAIT AGAIN- MADAM
INSPECTOR GENERAL WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
POLLACK FOR DEVOTING FOR YEAR
CONFIRMATION TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR MONNING SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU BOB MADAM INSPECTOR
GENERAL THAT'S KIND OF A NEAT
TITLE IS LYNETTE BACK TO BE
WEARING A UNIFORM AROUND HER
HOUSE BUT NOT REALLY BAD SO I
WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT TO VERY VERY
IMPORTANT POSITION IN SOMETHING
THAT WENT INTO SB ONE I THINK
THAT I WAS VERY MUCH A BI
PARTISAN AND DESIRE TO HAVE
SOMEONE WHO HAS THE
INDEPENDENCE FROM CALTRANS AND
WE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF ON THE
THINGS THAT OF SENATOR MONNING
MENTIONED. REGARDING THAT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN PARTICULAR LEAVE MEETING THE
EFFICIENCIES THAT WERE HOPE FOR
IS- WE LOOK AT TODD THOSE VERY
PRECIOUS DOLLARS GOING TO OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM SO I MY
QUESTION IS GOING TO FOCUS ON
YOUR INDEPENDENCE FROM CALTRANS
AND WHAT- SEASON PROCEDURES YOU
MAY HAVE THE IMPLEMENTED OR ARE
CONSIDERING HIM FOR BEING TO
ENSURE THAT YOU DO HAVE THAT.
IF A MEASURES SO PERHAPS CANDLE
IF YOU FEEL YOU NEED MORE TOOLS
AND THINGS THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT THE OFFICE OF HE HAS A
VERY GOOD WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH CALTRANS BUT THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE THERE
TO LOOK AND ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE MEETING THE TASKS THAT WERE
SET BEFORE THEM THROUGH SB ONE.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT AND YOUR
BATES- I THINK UP START OUT BY
TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. THE
OFFICE PRIOR TO YOU. SB ONE AND
THAT IS THAT IT WAS AN INTERNAL
ORGANIZATION WHICH WAS FOCUSED
ON CALTRANS MANAGEMENT
PRIORITIES. AND NOT IT'S WE'RE
PERFORMED ON DEMAND MANAGEMENT
DISCRETION. THE HIGHER LEVEL OF
EXPECTATIONS UNDER SB ONE
REQUIRES AYE AYES TO SHIFT TO A
MORE INDEPENDENT. RISK BASED
ORGANIZATION FOR FOCUSED ON
PERFORMANCE OUT. SO THESE
OPTIONS IT'S CRITICAL TO FOR ME
TO BEGIN WITH IN TERMS OF
ESTABLISHING THE INDEPENDENCE
THAT EMPLOYEE DEVELOPMENT IN
DIRECTION ON BECAUSE THIS IS A
CHANGE IN TERMS OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES WHO WERE THERE
PREVIOUSLY. JOINING THE
ORGANIZATION YEAH FOCUS FOR ME
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
ESTABLISHING INDEPENDENCE IN
HELPING THE STAFF TO UNDERSTAND
THAT IS FOCUSING ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND EDUCATION OUR
WORK PRODUCTS COMMUNICATION.
PRODUCT TO BE TOOLS IN ADDITION
THE OFFICE OF INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS FOLLOWS THE
YELLOW BOOK STANDARD. YELLOW
BOOK STANDARD DEEPER BY FOUR
AND REQUIRE A LEVEL OF
INDEPENDENCE BETWEEN THE WORK
OF THE AUDITORS AND THE WORK
THAT TO BE OUT OF IT. THERE ARE
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS
CONTINUING EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THE OTHER THING
STAFF TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
DOING THOSE THINGS AND IT
ABSOLUTELY IS A REQUIREMENT OF
THE YELLOW BOOK STANDARD AND
FOR US TO FOLLOW SH SO THE
INDEPENDENCE I THINK SHE IS
VESTED WITHIN THE PARAMETERS OF
THE PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS THAT
ARE FOLLOWED BY THE OFFICE. I
THINK THAT THE CHALLENGE.
HOPING THE STAFF TO UNDERSTAND
THE SEPARATION OF THOSE DUTIES
OR THAT RESPONSIBILITY. I THINK
THAT I WOULD JUST STOP THERE IN
TERMS OF THE INDEPENDENT
SUGGESTS THAT WE ARE MINDFUL OF
THAT INDEPENDENCE- BUT IT IS
ALSO IN HERE IT IN THE
STANDARDS THAT ARE FOLLOWED BY
MY OFFICE IN TERMS OF THE
CONDUCT OF. IT SHOULD BE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT ANSWER AND THAT
CERTAINLY GOES TO THE HEART OF
ALL THE THINGS THAT I WAS
LOOKING OUT OF I'M LOOKING OUT
TO THE NEW THE NEW ARE
POSITIONED IN CERTAINLY WHAT
YOU BRING TO THAT POSITION SO
I'M COMFORTABLE WITH THAT-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO SERVICE NOTICE YOU ARE TAKEN
SAFETY AND INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
THAT'S HOW I STARTED MY CAREER
INTX BEING. THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE DIESEL NO DOUBT T<c.cyan></c>
IS A VERY IMPORTANT JOB EVEN
OUT THE VERY SIMPLE LEVEL IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND YOU I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN THERE FOR CALTRANS
AND CERTAINLY OUR SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT THEY WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR- OUR- A GREAT.
TO IT AND THAT WE HAVE THE SO
THREE SHEET THAT AND YOU WILL
HAVE MY SUPPORT FOR YOUR
CONFIRMATION THANKS AGAIN. IN
HERE. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. BECKY AT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
EMPLOYMENT SO I LIKE TO FOLLOW
UP ON. SENATOR BATES QUESTION.
SO WE'VE NOW SWITCH FROM THIS
INTERNAL TO THIS EXTERNAL SO IS
A MAJOR PARADIGM SHIFT AND
COURSE. TRANSPORTATION VERY
LARGE CHAU ORGANIZATION SOME
JUST CURIOUS IN TERMS OF HOW
YOU WHAT CRITERIA DO YOU USE TO
PRIDE PRIORITIZE YOUR
INVESTIGATIONS. WELL
INVESTIGATIONS ARE PRIOR TO
PRIORITIZE BASED ON THE JUST
LAST SIGNIFICANCE OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE BEING BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION. THAT'S A VERY VERY
GOOD QUESTION- BASICALLY WHAT
WE DO IS WE LOOK AT WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS A THREAT TO.
PUBLIC SAFETY. OBVIOUSLY IF WE
SEE ANY ISSUES LIKE THAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE PRECEDENCE- WE
ALSO WORK ALONGSIDE A SEAT IN
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE AS WELL
AS U. S. D. O. T. ON ISSUES OF
CONCERN. SOMETIMES THOSE ISSUES
TAKE PRECEDENT OVER OTHERS- AND
CALTRANS THEY CAN BRING THINGS
TO OUR ATTENTION- THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE A SENSE OF
URGENCY AROUND. IN WHAT I THINK
WHAT I THINK IS HELPFUL IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE. IS THAT IT THERE'S A
BALANCE BETWEEN. OUR
INDEPENDENCE AND ALSO BEING
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS. URGENT
ISSUES THAT CALTRANS MAY BE
AWARE. OF THAT MAYBE WE GOT BUT
I THINK THAT THE PROCESS THAT
WE HAVE. LENDS ITSELF TO A GOOD
WORKING RELATIONSHIP BUT STILL
ALLOWING US TO BE SEPARATE
ENOUGH THAT WE CAN MAKE AN
INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE GOING ON. THANK
YOU FOR THAT AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS ON APPOINTMENT
AND FOR YOUR LONG STANDING
SERVICE MADAM CHAIR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN SAID
ROD THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM
ACTUALLY I HAVE NO WHAT
QUESTIONS MATTER INSPECTOR
GENERAL CONGRATULATIONS I'LL BE
SUPPORTING A CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
INSPECTOR GENERAL WE ARE NOW
GOING TO. MOVED TO ANYONE
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
AND WE'RE GONNA START WITH
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FOUR TWO
OH THREE AND LET ME JUST. SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT WANTS TO
COME FORWARD. OKAY SEEING NONE
ARE FOR PURPOSES OF COVERING
ALL THE BASES WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM WHICH I'M
SURE. IS PROBABLY HAS NO AND
NOT OVER FLOWN IF THAT'S A
WORD- TWENTY FORTY JUST DOUBLE
CHECKING TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE THERE. AND IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE DO. SO NOW
WE'RE GONNA ODD TURN AND BRING
IN TO JOIN US OUR MODERATOR- AS
SO IF THE MODERATOR COULD
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL CRAFT THEN WE WILL
BEGIN. SURE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT THREE IN THE QUEUE IT'LL
BE JUST A MOMENT. OKAY WHILE
WE'RE AWAITING THAT MOMENT LET
ME REMIND WITNESSES THAT WHEN
YOU SPEAK WE NEED YOU TO
PROVIDE YOUR NAME. THE
ORGANIZATION IF ANY THAT YOU'RE
REPRESENTING AND POSITION ON
THE APPOINTMENT. AND AGAIN- I
SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY FOR
THE BENEFIT OF OUR
STENOGRAPHER. OKAY THANK AND A
MODERATOR IF A- CALL THE
WITNESSES. SURE WELL FIRST GOTO
LINE SIXTEEN WE'VE GOT HAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS RAYMOND
HUNTER FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC AND SOCIAL
SERVICES. I'D LIKE TO FIRST OF
ALL- CONGRATULATE RHONDA RHONDA
AND I HAVE BEEN COLLEAGUES WITH
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLE RUN
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A TRAILBLAZER
BEACON OF LIGHT AND EXCEPTIONAL
LEADER. IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
HIGH SCHOOL IN WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I HAVE KNOWN
RHONDA FOR SEVERAL DECADES I
SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MAXWELL
TIMELINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS KEITH DONE I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SELF
HELP COUNTIES COALITION WHICH
IS TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES THAT
HAVE TAXED THEMSELVES TO
PROVIDE INFRASTRUCTURE CRITICAL
NEED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. I'M
PLEASED TO SUPPORT CONFIRMATION
IT'S CRACKED IN THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL ROLLING SB ONE WAS PUT
IN PLACE IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAD THE TYPES OF CHECKS
AND BALANCES OF THIS OFFICE
PROVIDES. CAN'T SUPPORT AND
AFFIRMATION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER AND
IDENTIFYING WAYS ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF. THE CODE THE PANDEMIC
TO DELIVER OUR INFRASTRUCTURE-
MORE EFFICIENTLY- AND IN IN THE
BEST MANNER THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE. SO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MAX GLOBAL CAROLINA ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES SIR GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MIKE MCGOWAN
AND THANK YOU FOR GIVING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR RHONDA
CRAFTED- MY BACKGROUND IS IN A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PRIMARILY
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
CITY COUNCIL IN THE WEST
SACRAMENTO AND YOU'LL COUNTY I
HAD THE HONOR OF WORKING WITH
HER FOR ABOUT FOUR YEARS OVER
THE OFFICER TRAFFIC SAFETY. OUT
YOU KNOW I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR IT I THINK SENATOR
OFFICE SO WELCOME THAT YOU
DON'T NEED TO SAY ANYTHING AND
I'M NOT I DON'T SEE TOO MUCH
EXCEPT I CANNOT SAY- STRONGLY
ENOUGH HOW MUCH I SUPPORTER AND
KNOW HOW WELL THE CITIZENS OF
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL BE SERVED. BY HER SERVICE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF MATTER MODERATOR ARE
THERE OTHER WITNESSES. HE AND I
HAVE ANYONE ELSE AND Q. AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE AND THEN
FERAL AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN THERE NOW.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WE WILL BE BACK WITH
YOU IN A MOMENT ARE LET'S COME
BACK INTO A ROOM FOR TWO OH
THREE AND- HEAR FROM ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. AND OF COURSE.
SEEING NO ONE IN OPPOSITION-
LET'S GO AHEAD AND CHECK ROOM
TWENTY FORTY JUST TO COVER OUR
BASES. AGAIN SEEING NO ONE
THERE IT DIDN'T MATTER
MODERATOR WE ARE COMING BACK TO
YOU FOR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE CONFIRMATION. CHAIR AND IF
YOU UP HOLD PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AGAIN IF YOU
OPPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THE MOMENT. THE
MODERATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH I
WILL COME BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
AND TURN TO MY VICE CHAIRMAN.
MOVE THE CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH INSPECTOR JUST LET ME
JUST ADD THAT I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALSO FOR YOUR SERVICE I
WANT TO BE ON RECORD TO SAY
THAT. AND PLEASED TO SUPPORT OF
THE CONFIRMATION. MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL. BATES HI BATES AYE
MONNING AYE MONNING AYE ROTH
ARE ROTH AYE WILK HI LOOK I
WOULD ATKINS FIVE. HI THAT IS
UNANIMOUS CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU. I'M GONNA- JUST WAIT
FOR A SECOND AND SEE IF FROM
THE SECRETARY WE NEED TO TAKE A
BREAK FOR THE STENOGRAPHER AT
THIS POINT I THINK WERE
PROBABLY FUN BUT I JUST WANT TO
DOUBLE CHECK. OKAY WONDERFUL-
SO NEXT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO.
THE NEXT APPOINTMENT AND- THAT
IS OF MS HILLARY EIGHT NORTON
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
WELCOME MS NORTON AND THANK YOU
FOR STANDING BY AND WAITING. I
WILL SAY TO YOU WHAT I SAID TO
INSPECTOR GENERAL IF YOU HAVE
ANYONE WITH YOU THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO OF KNOWLEDGE OR SOMEONE
YOU'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THE
WAY. THEN WE'LL COME RIGHT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS WELCOME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM PRETEND ATKINS AND SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH MY
DAUGHTER EVER AROSE GO. AND I'M
VERY PLEASED TO COME BEFORE YOU
TODAY AS A GOVERNOR APPOINTED
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM AND THE
ACTING CHAIR. OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION I
WANT TO THANK MY FAMILY MY
PARTNER MICHAEL LOMBARDI MY
CHILDREN HOW YEAR IT OF US AND
THE FATHER DROUGHT ROSE GO FOR
THEIR OF AN INCREASE. IT I WON
ALSO THANK YOU. FOR THE HONOR
OF WHAT. I THINK THOSE WHO
SUPPORTED MY APPOINTMENT AND MY
CDC COLLEAGUES TO UNANIMOUSLY
ELECTED ME TO BE VICE CHAIR
EARLIER THIS YEAR AND THE CDC
EXACT INSTRUCTOR BE TWICE. IT
IS AN HONOR TO SERVE CALIFORNIA
WITH YOU. I WANT TO THANK YOU
THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND VISION TO CREATE SB ONE AND
ENSURE THAT IT WAS NOT
OVERTURNED THROUGH PROPOSITION
SIX. THE D. C.'S HIGHEST
PRIORITY IS TO BE A GOOD
STEWARD OF THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN SB ONE FUNDS TO
CREATE GUIDELINES WITH SP ONE.
AND TO DEMONSTRATE TO THE
VOTERS ARE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
INTEGRITY THROUGH OUR WISE
INVESTMENTS SO THAT WE CAN SAY
PROMISES MADE PROMISES KEPT. IN
MY NINE MONTHS AT THE CDC I'VE
TRAVELED THE STATE LISTENING TO
NEEDS AND PRIORITIES OF PEOPLE
AROUND THE STATE NEED IS FUNDS
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. PEOPLE ASK WHEN
WILL RETURN TO NORMAL NORMAL
WILL BE AND I RESPONDED THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS PROBABLY NEVER
BEEN NORMAL. INSTEAD CALIFORNIA
IS A UNIQUE NATION STATE AS THE
GOVERNOR CALLS IT LEADING
AMERICA IN TRANSPORTATION
INNOVATION TECHNOLOGY CLIMATE
CHANGE MITIGATION AND ECONOMIC
GROWTH. RECOGNIZING THIS
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
LEADERS HAVE BEEN ASKED TO LEAD
AMERICA'S RECOVERY EFFORTS. SO
LET US NOT ASPIRE TO A NEW
NORMAL BUT RATHER TO IT NEXT
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. WELL
CALIFORNIA FACES EQUITY GAPS
RACIAL INEQUALITY CIVIL UNREST
BUDGET REDUCTIONS DOUBLE DIGIT
UNEMPLOYMENT AND THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CRISIS. INVEST IN YOUR-
THE STATE TRANSFER NETWORK CAN
THANKFULLY PART OF THE SLOW TO
ALL OF THESE CHALLENGES.
INTERPRETATION PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN BRIDGING
INEQUALITY AS STRONG MOBILITY
IS AN EMPOWERMENT TOOL.
CREATING NEW CAREER MAKING JOBS
PROVIDING ASKS US TO JOBS AND
EDUCATIONS PROMOTING RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC EQUITY IMPROVING
HEALTH AND AIR QUALITY
ENHANCING COMMUNITY IDENTITY.
STRONG TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
ALSO INDICATE STABILITY IN WHAT
FEELS LIKE RIGHT NOW AN
UNSTABLE WORLD THE PHRASE
TRAINS RUNNING ON TIME IS STILL
VERY PERTINENT TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DELIVER AS A SAFE
RELIABLE HEALTHY TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
DELIVER THE PEOPLE AND GOODS
THAT HAVE BEEN ARE LIFELINES
DURING THIS CALL THE NINETEEN.
AS ACT HERE MY FOR INITIATIVE
WILL BE THAT THIS. SEVEN
LISTENING STATE SESSIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE MOST CRITICAL
EQUITY ISSUES AFFECTING OUR
REGION'S AND HELP DETERMINE HOW
CDC PROGRAMS AND PROCESSES CAN
ADDRESS THEM. I BEGAN MY NEARLY
THIRTY YEAR CAREER IN LOS
ANGELES WORKING FOR THEN
COUNCIL MEMBER MARK RIDLEY
THOMAS IN SOUTH PHILLY RIGHT
AFTER THE NINETEEN NINETY TWO
OF PEOPLE ANOTHER PIVOTAL
MOMENT IN REYES AND JUSTICE. TO
ENSURE THAT BUILD BACK BETTER
REMINDS ME TO GUIDE ME TO THIS
DAY. AND WITH THAT IN MIND I'VE
SIX GOALS AS THE CDC
COMMISSIONER. ONE IS TO WISELY
INVEST SB ONE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDS IN PROJECTS THAT KELSO
CALTRANS A LOCAL AGENCY
RECOMMENDED. TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE NEXT CALL IT WILL ALSO
KEEPING OUR PROMISES VOTERS. TO
IS TO BE STRONGER PARTNERSHIPS
WITH OTHER AGENCIES WITH THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR STRONG
WORKING RELATIONSHIP HOUSE THE
SECOND. CAMP TRANS DIRECTOR
OVER SHOCK. CAR BIGELOW ACD
DIRECTOR GOES ALASKA'S OPR
DIRECTOR KATE GORDON ESSIE AND
ARE RESULT PARTNERS ARE
INVIGORATED TEAM WORKS IS
NECESSARY TO HELP ADDRESS THE
MYRIAD CHALLENGES AHEAD IN THE
MIDST OF BUDGET SHORTAGES.
THIRD IS FOR INNOVATION
LEVERAGING FEDERAL AND PRIVATE
FUNDS TO IMPLEMENT A CLEAN
MOBILITY NETWORK AND MEASURE
THE BENEFITS WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGY FOR IS TO ENHANCE
ALL MODES OF TRANSPORTATION
WHILE REBUILDING TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP. TO SUPPORT HEALTHY
DISTANCING IN HELPING ABILITY
DURING KOBE NINETEEN AND CREATE
MORE CAREER MAKING JOBS TO
REBUILD OUR ECONOMY. NUMBER
FIVE IS TO STRENGTHEN OUR GOODS
MOVE WORK THROUGH SIX
INVESTMENTS IN OUR ROADWAYS.
ASIAN IN IN PASSENGER RAIL AND
TRANSIT TO DO REDUCE DRIVING IN
A SPEED FREAK TRIPS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND FINALLY NUMBER
SIX INCREASED PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
TO ENSURE EQUITY FOR ALL. EVERY
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO RECALL
OWNERSHIP AS SYSTEM RIDERS
CONSTRUCTORS OPERATORS AND
INVESTMENT. IN CLOSING THE NEXT
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL IS ON THE
MOVE. I THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING MY CONFIRMATION
TODAY SO THAT I MAY CONTINUE TO
SERVE ON THE CDC AND BE PART
CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY AND VERY
VERY BRIGHT FUTURE. I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MS NORTON SENATOR
ROTH THANK YOU MAN PRO TEM-
CONGRATULATIONS VENTURE. HIGHLY
QUALIFIED AND A WELL DESERVED A
NOMINATION. I HAPPEN TO
REPRESENT- WESTERN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND WE DID NOT A
QUESTION BUT A COMMENT WE HAD A
WE HAVE HAD AN ISSUE. INVOLVING
THE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
AND AS YOU KNOW- THE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM IS IN
EXISTENCE PRIOR TO SP ONE AND
IT WAS CARRIED OVER- WITH SP
ONE AND AS- IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE PROGRAM LOCAL COUNTIES
WERE. INCENTIVIZE TO PASS A
LOCAL TAX MEASURE FOR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING AND THEN
THE LOCAL A PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
PROVIDED MATCHING FUNDING. OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY HAS LONG BEEN
A SELF HELP COUNTY AND
CONTINUES TO BE ONE.
HISTORICALLY THIS L. P. P.
p5% ALLOCATION FORMULA. THOSE OF
US WHO VOTED FOR SB ONE
CERTAINLY THIS SENATOR ASSUMED
THAT THAT HISTORICAL FORMULA
WOULD CONTINUE ON WITH SB ONE.
IN THE- SP ONE WAS NOT SPECIFIC
AS TO THE FORMULA ALLOCATION
FOR THE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. FUNDS THAT WERE THAT
FLOW THROUGH TO THE PROGRAM
AFTER THE VOTE. SOMETIME AFTER
THE VOTE SOME OF US WERE
INFORMED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT IT WAS NOT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S AUTHORITY TO
CONTINUE THIS STORE PRACTICE
INSTEAD TO GIVE THE CTC FULL
DISCRETION. YEAH HOW TO
ALLOCATE THE MONEY. BUT THAT
WAS SOMEWHAT BOTHERSOME TO SOME
OF US THERE WAS SOME
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS- BY SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES TO. FIX A FORMULA
OR AT LEAST A FORMULA RANGE
WHICH WERE. FIND SUCCESSFUL
WHEN THE EFFORTS REACHED THE
HORSESHOE. AND OF COURSE THAT'S
THE GOVERNOR'S PROVOCATIVE BUT
WHAT I WOULD ASK AND IT IS
CLEAR THAT THE CDC HAS THE
DISCRETION IN THE AUTHORITY TO
SET THAT ALLOCATION FORMULA BUT
WHAT I WOULD ASK OF YOU IN YOUR
CAPACITY. AS THE CDC
COMMISSIONER AND AS CHAIR WHEN
YOU ARE CONFIRMED AND I FULLY
INTEND TO SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION AND IN FACT. MAKE
THE MOTION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT YOU AND
YOUR FELLOW COMMISSIONERS TAKE
THE- HISTORICAL PRACTICES AT
LEAST. INTO ACCOUNT IN MAKING
DECISIONS WITH THE- WITH REGARD
LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM IN
THE FUTURE. AND THAT'S MY
COMMENT AND THAT'S MY REQUEST
AND WITH THAT. CONGRATULATIONS
AGAIN I LOOK FORWARD TO MAKING
THAT MOTION THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM. THANK YOU ARE MISSING DO
YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT
BEFORE I GO TO OUR VICE
CHAIRMAN. I THINK. I BECAME UC
CTC COMMISSIONER AFTER A GREAT
DEAL OF THE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THE ALLOCATION FORMULAS HAD
OCCURRED I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO KEEP IN
MIND I TAKE. SENATORS REQUEST
VERY SERIOUSLY AND IT WILL BE
PART OF OUR CONSIDERATION AS WE
WORK WITH THIS NEW SET OF
GUIDELINES AND OUR NEW REVIEW A
PROJECTS AND I'D LIKE TO MEET
WITH. FOUR WE FINISHED THOSE
REVIEWS AND TO TALK FURTHER
ABOUT HIS CONCERNS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OKAY
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT IT AND WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOU I WILL NOT BE MAKING THE
MOTION BECAUSE CENTER ROTH. HAS
THAT HONOR I DO BUT I REALLY
JUST ONE MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS
FIRST OF ALL I WANTED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR STRONG APPLICATION FOR
MORE COMMUTER RAIL ON MITCHELL
LINKS ON NORTHERN EL COUNTY TO
DOWNTOWN LA. ALREADY KNOW THE
FOURTEEN FREEWAYS ALREADY.
BURDENED AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CCAC PROJECTIONS FOR HOUSING
IT'S ALL COMING TO NORTH COUNTY
I'M NOT SURE HOW WE'RE GOING TO
ACCOMMODATE ALL THAT GROWTH.
BUT ONE WAY OBVIOUSLY IS
INCREASE COMMUTER RAIL SO I
KNOW YOU'RE A STRONG ADVOCATE
ON THAT. IT'S SOMETHING NEAR TO
DEAR TO MY HEART THAT YOU BEEN
AND JUST A LEADER ON IS IN THE
MODERNIZATION. HI FIVE THROUGH
NEW HALL PASS. EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM AND EVERYBODY KNOW
WHAT YEAH STANDS SIMPLE THE I.
FIVE RIGHT IT'S THE- BC TO BC
BARK. TO BRITISH COLUMBIA BUT
THE CHOKE POINT IS THERE THE
NEW HALL PASS IN THE SENATE
CREATIVE ALLEY. SO UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND THE THINGS THAT
HAVE. THAT HAVE HAPPENED ARE
GONNA HAPPEN. THAT INCREASES
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR. MY
CONSTITUENTS PERCENTER STEARNS.
AND BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY BUT
JUST AS IMPORTANT- THE GOODS
MOVEMENT WHICH IS IMPORTANT. TO
OUR ECONOMY SO AGAIN I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FOR YOU MATTER CHAIR
AND A LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING
FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS. AND THANK YOU
MISTER VICE. ARE THE SENATOR
BATES IN YOU THANK. ON THE ME
AB. ON TO MY COLLEAGUES AND
WHEN I READ YOUR RESPONSES TO.
THE QUESTIONS- MISS NORTON I
SAID HERE'S A PERSON AFTER MY
OWN HEART YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
LOOKING AT SYKORA. SO THAT CAN
BE STREAMLINED FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS BECAUSE
IT WAS ALWAYS DISTURBING TO US
OUT IN THE- OUT IN THE MOVIES
THAT IT TOOK OF NOT. LESS THAN
SEVEN YEARS JUST TO GET
SOMETHING MOVING ON THE GROUND
WITH SOME OF THE MONEY THAT WAS
THERE BACK ALL OF THE PROCESS
BEING IN THE- OPPORTUNITIES.
PULLING A DEBT SEEK CHALLENGE.
SALUTE AND HOUSE. YOU HAVE ONE.
ARE FOR YOU REGARDING THE
DECLINE IN OUR GAS TAX REVENUES
AS A RESULT OF CODED NINETEEN.
YONDER WIND OUT TO WHEN WE HAD
TO KIND OF A SET BACK WITH. THE
EARLIER RECESSION. WERE ARE
PROJECTS THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
A REMOVED FROM CONSIDERATION
AND MIGHT HAVE BEEN ALREADY
APPROVED IN NINE AND CAN I AM I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT HOW WHEN WE-PRIORITIZE. PROJECTS TO
CONTINUE RECEIVE FUNDING OR
THAT ARE COMING IN THE QUEUE TO
RECEIVE FUNDING HOW WILL YOU
APPROACH THAT PRIORITIZATION IT
WASN'T RELIEF LEE. HOW TO MY
DISTRICT AT THE OUTSET. RIGHT
THOSE ARE THINGS OUT TO I KNOW
LOOKING OUT WHAT CONDITION
MANAGEMENT IS REQUIRED FOR
THEIR QUALITY AND THE BASINS
AND ALL OF THOSE FACTORS THAT
GO INTO THAT BUT SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN WAITING A
LONG TIME. THEY'RE JUST ON THE
QUEUE REDY TO GO AND THEN WE
GOT WORD THAT SOME OF THEM WERE
GOING TO BE REMOVED AND- THAT
WAS TROUBLING BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
SEEM TO BE A REAL. CRITERIA
THAT PRIOR. SO COULD YOU SHARE
SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS OF HOW
YOU MIGHT PRO CHOICE OUT OF
THAT'S GOING TO BE SOMETHING ON
YOUR AGENDA COMING UP. SURE I
THINK IT'S A GREAT QUESTION I
THINK. THAT ARE BATES FOR THAT
QUESTION. I THINK. BECAUSE WE
ARE FACING. CONSTRAINTS ON
FUNDS THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE GOING
STATE WIDE TO TALK TO PEOPLE
ABOUT HOW THE WORLD HAS CHANGED
WITH KOBE NINETEEN. WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
POSITIONING PROJECTS AND THE
BEST WAYTO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING OUT LATE
AND NEED A MATCH WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE. BEING
THE WISEST STEWARD OF FUNDS AND
SO WE ARE GOING TO LOOK AT ALL
OF THESE PROJECTS AND AS AND
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN EXPEDITE
OTHER PLANS THAT COULD.
POTENTIALLY ADD MORE MONEY INTO
THE SYSTEM SUCH AS- EXPANDING.
WIDE NETWORK OF EXPRESS LANES
AND TOLL LANES BECAUSE THOSE
HAVE SUCH PROFOUND BENEFITS. TO
MOBILITY BUT ALSO TO TRANSIT
THEY HELP MOVE PEOPLE AWAY
FROM- THE GOODS WILL BE COURT
ORDERS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON.
ADDRESSING WHERE GAS TAX MAY
FALTER POTENTIALLY EVEN WITH
OTHER WAYS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE PER MILE CHARGE ETCETERA
SO THAT. WE DON'T HAVE TO SAY
NO THIS PROJECTS THAT PEOPLE
ARE COUNTING ON BUT TO LOOK AT
INSTEAD HOW DO WE INVEST IN THE
VERY PROJECTS THAT ARE GOING TO
HAVE THESE MULTIPLE NETWORK
BENEFITS AND IN. LOOTING THE
ENVIRONMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE ARE KEEPING OUR PROMISES
WITH THE VOTERS WE'RE KEEPING
PROMISES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
THAT MADE VERY COURAGEOUS
DECISIONS. FOR SB NINE AND BACK
PROP SIX. SO I NEED. SENSING SO
IN THE NEW HOPE IN NINETEEN.
THANK YOU THAT I'M I'M CALM
WITH THE YEAR POINT BECAUSE I
FEEL THAT YOU HAVE A REAL CLOSE
CA. WITH THE DISK HAND IS
NEEDED TO AND WE'LL GIVE IT A
FAIR SHOT AND CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
EMBRACE IT FAR PROJECT COMES UP
ON THE CUT LIST OR A LITTLE
CUTTING ARE ABOUT I THINK
THEY'LL BE AN EXPLANATION THERE
AND IF NOT I'LL BE CALLING YOU
SO. CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YEAR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR MINING THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THE CHAIR
NORTON LET ME AND MY
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- DEDICATED SERVICE
THROUGH THE YEARS. I ENJOYED
OUR CONVERSATION EARLIER TODAY
AND I THINK ONE OF YOUR
RESPONSES IF YOU COULD SHARE IT
AGAIN I THINK IT IN YOUR
OPENING YOU TALK KIND OF
MADDENING INTERCONNECTION OF
COVERT NINETEEN RACIAL
INJUSTICE AND THE CLIMATE
CRISIS YOUR RESPONSE TO ONE OF
MY QUESTIONS AS A LEADER OF
FAST IN THE- THAT TOLL LANES IN
LOS ANGELES. THE QUESTION WAS.
HOW DID YOU USE THE NET
PROCEEDS TO SUPPORT IMPACTED
COMMUNITY SIR ADJACENT
COMMUNITIES AND I THINK IT
WOULD BE VALUABLE FOR MY
COLLEAGUES TO HEAR HOW THAT'S
BEEN PUT INTO ACTION NOT JUST
THEORETICAL. HAVE BEEN VERY
INTERESTING IF YOU COULD SHARE
SOME OF THAT THANK YOU WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
MINING I REALLY ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION TODAY AND UP WE
HAD A GREAT DISCUSSION ABOUT
HOW EXPRESS LANES IN TOLL LANES
CAN BE AN EMPOWERMENT TOOL FOR-
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT. RIGHT
FROM THE OUTSET AND I WAS
PLEASE TO SEE THE LEADERSHIP OF.
STEPHANIE WIGGINS WHO IS NOW
THE CEO METROLINK WHO WHO RAN
THIS THIS PROGRAM IT WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST- ON THE WEST COAST.
OF THE PART THAT WE HAD WITH
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WAS THAT HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION OF THE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION ALL RIGHT INTO
THE BUS SYSTEM SO WE NOT ONLY
MADE SURE THAT WITH THAT YOU
HAD GOOD. BUSES WE HAD. FUNDS
TO THE NET TOLL REVENUE AS YOU
PASSED GO TO THINGS OR- METRO
BIKE SHARE THEY WENT TO
LIGHTING AND SAFE STATION ALONG
THESE CORRIDORS THAT MEANT.
BETTER MOBILITY AND WE MADE
SURE THAT THERE WERE THINGS
LIKE THE EQUITY PROGRAM FOR THE
ON BANKS SO THAT PEOPLE. HATE
YOU A TRANSPONDER BUT DIDN'T
HAVE TO HAVE A BANK YOU DON'T
THINK IT PAYING PASSED THE
DIDN'T HAVE TO HAVE IT ON A-
CREDIT CARD. IN ADDITION I
THINK WHAT HAS BEEN A HALLMARK
OF WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH THE NET
TOOL PROGRAM AND WHAT I HOPE IS
INCLUDED IN FUTURE. EXPRESSED
IN PROGRAMS IS THAT WITHIN THAT
MY RADIUS. IS TOLL. LAKE EVEY-
CONVERSION INTO THE ADA
COMPLIANT VEHICLES WE HAD. IN
ADDITION AS PART OF THE EXPRESS
LANES PEOPLE HAVE NOTED THAT IN
ORDER TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
EXPRESS LANES AS A DRIVER IT
WAS THE BASIS OF 40% OF NEW
EVEY VEHICLES BEING PURCHASED
THAT WAS A UCLA STUDY AND SO IN
THAT NOT ONLY DID WE REDUCE
TRAFFIC REDUCE IDOLING. WE CAN
ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT INTO EVEY
TRANSPORTATION SO IN THE VERY
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEING
IMPACTED BY ASTHMA AND OBESITY
AND- HIGH PRESSURE AND ALL OF
THESE EMERGING ISSUES THAT ARE
MAKING PEOPLE EVEN MORE
VULNERABLE TO COVERT NINETEEN
WE WERE ABLE TO LOOK AT HOW TO
CLEAN THE AIR MOVE PEOPLE
BETTER AND GET PEOPLE TO MORE
JOBS ALONG THESE CORRIDORS THE
NEVER HAD. FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GEN I THINK. THE ONE THEME
THAT CAME OUT OF OUR
CONVERSATION WAS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IS INTERCONNECTED WITH
HOW WE APPROACH TRANSPORTATION
SO. THANK YOU FOR THAT IN A
MADAM CHAIR I HAVE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT-
THE NOMINATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU. IF
YOU SEND A THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR LEBRETON. YES SENATOR
AWFUL YES PLEASE. I'M SURE OF
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT GOOD TO
MAY NOT FALL WITHIN YOUR
SANDBOX BUT I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE YOU WILL WERE OF IT IS OF.
THE RULE MAKING PROCESS GOING
TO DEAL WITH VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED AND TRANSPORTATION
WERE IN ESSENCE- NO ADDITIONAL
TRANSPORTATION MILES IN TERMS
OF LANES. CAN BE APPROVED AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. UNLESS IF IT IF
IT INCREASES THE NUMBER OF
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED NOW WHEN
YOU LIVE IN WESTERN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY RIVERSIDE COUNTY IS YOU
KNOW. MOST OF OUR JOBS ARE IN A
HIGHLY IN THE URBANIZED COASTAL
AREAS LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY.
BUT DUE TO THE AVAILABILITY OF
LAND IN THE COST OF LAND AND
HOUSING. THE HOUSING DEVELOPS
OUT WHERE I COME FROM. SO IT IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO MOVE
PEOPLE FROM WHERE I AM TO THE
JOBS UNTIL WE SOMEHOW BALANCE
OUT OUR JOBS NO WE HAVE A
HOUSING POLICY THAT ENCOURAGES
HOUSING IN FACT REQUIRES
HOUSING TO BE BUILT WHERE I AM.
DEVELOP TATIAN POP DISCOURAGE.
THE LAYING OF NEW ROADWAY. TO
MOVE PEOPLE WHO MOVE TO THOSE
HOUSES. ARE WE HAVE VIRTUALLY
NO TRANSIT IN TERMS OF
EFFECTIVE BUS. WHERE I AM THE
LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY
FOR JOBS AND THE RAIL LINES ARE
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE IN TERMS OF
TIME AND FREQUENCY. SO I THINK
IS A STATE AND AS I SAID I
DON'T THINK THIS FALLS WITHIN
THE C. D. C.'S PURVIEW. BUT AS
A STATE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN
OUR HOUSING POLICY. OUR
TRANSPORTATION POLICY AND AS A
MATTER OF FACT THROUGH THE TO
GO BECAUSE WE ENCOURAGE
BUSINESSES TO MOVE TO THE
COASTAL AREAS. OR EXPAND IN THE
COASTAL AREAS. WITHOUT
REQUIRING THE COASTAL OR IS TO
DEVELOP THE HOUSING SO I
THOUGHT IS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION YOU SHOULD AT LEAST
BE AWARE OF THE DISCONNECT AND
HELP US. IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT THAT. AND TRY TO GET SOME.
FOLKS WHO HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
TO FOCUS. ON THOSE ISSUES I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND SORRY
TO BRING THAT UP AT THE END BUT
WILL HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT THAT LATER. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM
THANK YOU ARE SENATOR ROTH AND
IN FACT THAT IS A- DISCUSSION
THAT WILL CONTINUE- IN THE
SENATE BECAUSE IT HAS BECOME A
DISCUSSION AS PART OF. SOME OF
THE LEGISLATION THAT WE HAVE
AROUND HOUSING. I AND-
CERTAINLY JOBS BY. WHICH WE
INTEND OF COURSE HOPEFULLY AS-
THE WORLD RETURNS TO NORMAL AND
WE HAVE A MORE. OF THAT OUR
REGULAR PROCESS OF ABILITY TO
DISCUSS AND HAVE HEARINGS AND-
ODD DEBATE THESE ISSUES THAT WE
INTEND TO TAKE UP NEXT YEAR OR
SO- RIGHT. HE FOR BRINGING THAT
UP LET ME CONFER WITH MY
COMMENTS IN TERMS OF. YOUR
EXPERIENCE YOUR COMMITMENT
OBVIOUSLY YOUR RESUME. AND
CERTAINLY THE SUPPORT THAT I
HAVE HEARD FOR YOU PRIOR TO THE
HEARING TODAY- WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND I'M GOING TO DO A
BIT OF A REMINDER FOR WITNESSES
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA
PHONE. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN FIVE
ZERO TWO ZERO ONE THREE I WILL
REPEAT IT AGAIN THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS
CODE IS. 750-201-3750 ZERO ONE
THREE SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE IN ROOM
FOUR TWO OH THREE AND THERE IS
ONE- I WANNA A WELCOME YOU
TODAY YEAH AT THE MICROPHONE
AND- NAME OF THE ORGANIZATION.
IF ANY AND YOUR COMMENTS
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM OF
PROTEST MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. IT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE YOU NEED
MUCH PERSUASION BUT WE ARE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF MIST- NORTON'S
CONFIRMATION TO THE CTC. L.
ELLIE METRO IS VERY PLEASED
THAT THE GOVERNOR REAPPOINTED
MISS NORTON TO THE COMMISSION.
WE HAVE FOUND HER TO BE A VERY
EFFECTIVE ADVOCATE AT CTC. SHE
REALLY DIGS INTO THE ISSUES
WORKS TO SOLVE PROBLEMS. I
THINK REPRESENTATION TODAY
ABOUT HER YOU KNOW SIX GOALS IN
THE WAY SHE APPROACHES THINGS.
IS INDICATIVE OF THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE PLUS YEARS THAT
SHE'S BEEN INVOLVED IN PUBLIC
POLICY AND- COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT- AND OF COURSE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. WHEN IT
COMES TO TRANSPORTATION WHAT WE
FOUND AT THIS. WE ARE BE MUCH
ABOUT. LOCAL EQUITY AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ACROSS
THE STATE. AND FOR LA METRO IN
PARTICULAR- SHE SUPPORTS AND IS
VERY ACTIVE IN ISSUES THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO METRO AND TO OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS INCLUDING.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. AS WELL
AS THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. AND FOR THOSE WHO
APPEAR BEFORE HER BEFORE THE
CTC AS I THINK SHE'S
DEMONSTRATED. SHE'S OBVIOUSLY
SMART AS A WHIP AND WITH THAT.
OF MADAME PRO TEM WE URGE YOUR
CONFIRMATION MISTER BURN TO THE
COMMISSION THANK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE A YOU HAVE
WAITED THREE HEARINGS TO BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY- IT AT OUR
RULES COMMITTEE SO WE'RE
THRILLED. TO HAVE YOU HERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
FOUR TWO OH THREE. OKAY SEEING
NONE WE'RE GONNA GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY JUST TO MAKE SURE
WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE THERE. I
DO NOT SEE ANYONE MOVING
FORWARD SO WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO OF MADAME MODERATOR
WHO IS WAITING FOR US- AND WE
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MANTA
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE PROP
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT. SURE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
TERREL NOW AGAIN TO SHOW
THERE ARE ALL. WE HAVE ABOUT
TEN AND THEY KILL LOCAL CO LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS HANJOUR
EMPLOYEE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI. THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES- THE LOS ANGELES WORLD
AIRPORTS AUTHORITY AND- LOS
ANGELES BARBARA TRANSPORTATION.
OR NORTON'S CONFIRMATION TO THE
CDC THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WELL MEXICO CAROLINE
EIGHT PM PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR GOT SCORE IN
BEHALF OF THE SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS THE
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
ASSOCIATION THE GOVERNMENT THE
STANISLAUS COUNTY GOVERNMENT
AND THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
FOR MODERATE. JUST VERY BRIEFLY
WANT TO SAY THE COMMISSIONER
NORTON HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
ACCEPTABLE BOB FOR HER VIEWS OF
ADDRESS HE CONGESTION
MANAGEMENT AND IT'S TAKEN A
REAL INTEREST IN LEARNING HOW
REGION STATEWIDE PROVIDING
MULTI MODAL XIN. MOVING PEOPLE
COMMERCE. IN ADDITION. I WANTED
TO GRAB HER ON HER. I WON'T
HOLD IT AGAINST HER THAT SHE
THE SEATTLE SEAHAWKS FAN AND
THAT WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
STYLE HER CONFIRMATION THE
STOCKING AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU MAY HAVE TO START THE
HEARING ALL OVER AGAIN. OUR IS
IT. THAT MAN MONTEREY NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. CHERYL COULD
NOT GO TO LINE NINETEEN PLEASE
GLAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
GERARD RIGHT I'M A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY RESIDENTS PARTICULARLY
LONG BEACH I I'VE KNOWN ELLERY
NORTON FOR WELL OVER A DECADE
AND I AM PLEASED TO- HAVE YOUR
HAVE YOU GUYS COME FROM HER. TO
THIS ALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION I KNOW SHE'S GOING
TO DO A GREAT JOB AS HE'S DONE
HERE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE
PERSONAL FRIEND COLLEAGUE JUST.
I LOVED THE CHANGES AND THE
VISION ISSUE OUT FOR
TRANSPORTATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU AGAIN
AND CONGRATULATIONS. THANK SO
MUCH WITNESS. THANKS GO TO LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
TRACEY HERNANDEZ THE FOUNDING
CEO OF THIS SAID LOS ANGELES
INVESTMENT CENTRAL VALLEY YOU
MAY KNOW THAT WERE MASSIVE
NETWORK OF BUSINESS NETWORK WE
HAVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
BUSINESSES LARGE AND SMALL AND
WE ALL STAND UNITED AND STRONG
SUPPORT FOR HILLARY NORTON.
CONFIRMATION AS YOU CAN SEE-
SHE EATS. LEAN MARINES GREAT
TRANSPORTATION BLOOM. WE'VE
SEEN THAT LIVE THOUGH SHE HAS
CHAIRED OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS
ARE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
AND SHE WAS EVEN THOUGH THE
CHAIR AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SHE'S HIGHER LOWER CONSENSUS
BUILDER AND LEADER AND SHE WAS
VERY FOCUSED ON MOBILITY FOR
ALL WE STRONGLY ORDER AND
CONGRATULATIONS COMMISSIONER
NINE. THANK YU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. ONE MEXICO TRYING
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HAPPENING CHAIR- MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JOE COLBORNE HIGH AND I
WORK WITH THE FACT THAT A
REGIONAL TRANSIT DISTRICT I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH. NO ONE
PERSONALLY FOR. EVEN BEFORE I
JOIN CRACKER T. AND PRIOR TO
HER APPOINTMENT TO SEE. THE
SHIP IN A STRONG CHAMPION A
MULTI MODAL TRANSPORTATION
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND- AS
YOU HEARD TODAY WALTER MANTRA
ALWAYS BEEN IF THEY- ARE HARD
WORKING FAMILIES. LET ME ASK
YOU TO SORRY THAT ODD TO THE TO
THE WITNESS LET ME ASK YOU TO
SLOW DOWN JUST A BIT. OF FOR
THE STENOGRAPHER THANK YOU.
YEAH THANK YOU I APPRECIATE IT.
I JUST REMEMBER VIVIDLY THAT
MISS NORTON. ONE WELL ATTENDED
COMMUNITY MEETING SHE RAISED
ISSUES OF SAY SPEAKER FOR WOMEN
THE ELDERLY BUT THE VEHICLE
ENSURING THAT WE INCLUDE THEM
AND HOW WE PLAN. AND INVESTED.
HELLO HER LEADERSHIP AND
SERVICE IN ASSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS FROM OUR COMMUNITY
WHETHER THEY COME FROM
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIFFERENT ARE
VERY SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS I'VE BEEN IMPROVE
QUALITY OF LIFE WHETHER YOU
DRIVE A CAR DELIVERED BUT IN A
FREIGHT TRUCK RIGHT THE LIGHT
RAIL BIKE WILL WALK AROUND THE
CITY I BELIEVE THE MYTH NORTON
WOULD BE FAIR AN ATTENTIVE EAR
FOR BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
ENTITIES INTRACTABLE. WITHIN A
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ADDRESS THE
STATE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY. FOR OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A PERSON IN THE SONG THE
SHERIN POLICY BODY LIKE THE CPC
AND AGAIN. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. ONE NEXT
COURT TIMELINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GLAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE WEEKEND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR METROLINK.
WHITE MEN OF HILLARY NORTON AS
A COMMISSIONER REFLECT OUR
STATE COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING
THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
TRANSPORTATION. SURE NORTON
BACKGROUND IN COALITION
BUILDING AND FOR THINKING
POLICY IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO TRANSFORM OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WE
APPRECIATE THE ROLE OF THE TTC
AND MEETING THE STATE'S
PRESSING NEED DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIME. AND I CAN
THINK OF NO ONE BETTER TO LEAD
THE CTC AT THIS TIME AND I URGE
THE PORT OF COMMISSIONER NORTON
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. ONE
ACT GO TIMELINE TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I AM A PLAYER
SCHLECHTER BUT AS AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT GOVERNOR FAIRS
FORTY BEVERLY US CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND ON THOSE SPEAKING
ON MY OWN BEHALF. AMONG THE
PEOPLE I KNOW I REALLY SHOULD
NORTON IS JUST THE BEST PERSON
TRANSPORTATION ANYONE I KNOW-
THE PERSON CHARACTER AND GOOD
JUDGMENT AND REALLY IS THE GO
TO PERSON WHEN I THINK OF
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES AND
TAKING THOUGHT ABOUT THEM SO.
G. O. SUPPORT IN AND THERE
SHOULD BE A GREAT JOB THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. THANKS TO LINE TWENTY
FIVE PREVIOUS CAR. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN
POLANSKI. ON THE CALTRANS
DISTRICT SEVEN DIRECTOR WHICH
COVERS LOS ANGELES AND VENTURA
COUNTIES. I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT. BUT THE
CONFIRMATION IMAGE HILLARY
NORTON THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION GEN. DID YOU ARE
FULLY AWARE THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA IS CRUCIAL
TO THE SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
VITALITY OF THIS STATE. COVER
DATE IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
REINFORCED THIS FACT. YES
MORTON FULLY UNDERSTANDS THE
COMPLEXITIES. THIS SYSTEM IN
THE IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY AND
DEVELOPMENT OF INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES. MISS NORTON PROMOTES
WHEN NEED FOR A BALANCED SYSTEM.
THAT PROVIDES MORAL CHOICES
WHICH WILL RESULT IN IMPROVED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONFIRM MISS
NORTON CTC APPOINTMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. ONE NEXT COURT
TIMELINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
CALL HAD. LINE TWENTY EIGHT
YOU'RE OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED
ON YOUR END. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. HEY ARE GIPSON GLORIA
MOLINA PLAN THAT PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. CHAMBER
AND MYSELF PERSONALLY BOTH
STRONGLY SUPPORT EARLY HELLO RE
NORTON APPOINTMENT WE'VE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH HER FOR THE PAST.
IN HER POSITION AS CO CHAIR OF
THE CHAMBERS TRANSPORTATION AND
GOODS MOVEMENT COUNCIL SH IN
THAT ROLE SHE HAS DEMONSTRATED
BOTH LEADERSHIP AND DEEP
KNOWLEDGE OF THE INTERSECTION
OF TRANSPORTATION HOW BEING
INNOVATION AND EQUITY. SHE HAS
A NUANCED APPROACH TO FOR CASE
THAT MEANT THAT NECESSARY AS WE
APART FIRST TREAT
TRANSPORTATION. THE COURT HEARD
ME. THANK YOU GRAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. ONE NINE GOAL TIME
LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED ON YOUR
END. OR MEXICO TIMELINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MA'AM PRO TENNIS IS KEYSTONE
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SELF HELP COUNTIES COALITION
I'D LIKE TO CONGRATULATE MY
FRIEND- MISS NORTON ON HER.
PAYMENT AND- WE WOULD- PLEASED
TO HAVE HER USE OUR LONG
STANDING MODEL PROMISES MADE
PROMISES KEPT WE'RE HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT AS YOUR SOCIAL
COUNTIES WITH THE CDC. IT'S
IMPORTANT MOTTO NOW WE'VE MADE
WITH OUR VOTING PUBLIC AND I'M
PLEASED TO SEE HER USE IT SO
READILY IN HER CONFIRMATION
PROCESS. ALSO LIKE TO THE THINK
SENATOR ROSS FOR HIS INQUIRY
ABOUT THE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM- THE SUFFOLK AS A
FACTOR OF THAT PROGRAM AND HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. FALLOUT EXACT TO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS WHEN HE IS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST SAID HE DID GIVE
US A FAIR PROCESS TO WEIGH IN
AND PROVIDE OUR OPINIONS AND
THEN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THAT
PROGRAM AND THERE'S DIFFERENT
OPINIONS CERTAINLY THAT I. THE
PROGRAM WENT BUT WE DID HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY WITH NOW XECUTER
AFTER WEISS TO PROVIDE INPUT.
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH-
MISS HORTON IN HER NEW ROLE
AND- AND EXCITED TO HAVE HER AS
A PART OF OUR TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTIONS. CITY CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. ON MEXICO TO LINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE CALL HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KENDALL
ATTENTION ON I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND I ALSO
WORK AT THE ONLY CHAMBER TO
SUPPORT A HILLARY NORTON'S
APPOINTMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION I'VE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH HER IN MY
WORK AT THE CHAMBER AND SHE HAS
PROVEN TO BE AN EXCELLENT
LEADER AT. THE PORT OF HAD
MENTIONED SHE'S ALWAYS PUSHED
ON. ROUND THE INTERSECTION
TRANSPORTATION MOBILITY AND
INNOVATION. I AM REALLY HAPPY
TO SEE HER CONTINUING TO WORK-
ON THESE ISSUES AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
MODERATOR ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES. THERE IS NO ONE AND
I KILL AT THE MOMENT BUT AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS THE WHY AND THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
AND THERE'S NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
AT THE MOMENT. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH MATTER MODERATOR WE
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU IN A FEW
MOMENTS. LET'S DO THE SAME
PROCESS FOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION- WE WILL START WITH
ROOM FOR TWO OH THREE WHERE WE
ARE NOW. ANYWAY THIS. TO COME
FOR. SEEING NO ONE LET'S GO
AHEAD AND GO TO TWENTY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY JUST TO COVER OUR
BASES. I DON'T SEE ANYONE
COMING FORWARD IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SO MADAME MODERATOR WE
ARE COMING BACK TO YOU- TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ON THE LINE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE
CONFIRMATION OF MS NORTON. IF
YOU WISH TO UPHOLD PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN FERAL AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO NOW. AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN Q. AT THE MOMENT. OKAY
OUR MAN MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE AND
HELP TODAY WE GREATLY
APPRECIATED. I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS AND HAVE
BEEN FORGOTTEN WHICH ONE ONE
THE- COIN TOSS A SENATOR ROTH
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TO MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FAITH HI BATES
AYE MONNING AYE MONNING AYE
ROTH ARE ROTH AYE WILK HI WILK
I ATKINS AYE INSIDE GRADUATIONS
UNANIMOUS. THANK YOU TO AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO INSPECTOR
GENERAL RHONDA CRAFT AS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND YOUR BOTH THOUGHT STILL
THERE I SEE AND I WOULD JUST
SAY IT'S NOT ALWAYS THIS QUICK
EASY AND SMOOTH SO THAT IS A
TESTAMENT OBVIOUSLY- TO THE
APPOINTMENTS IN THE WORK THAT
EACH OF YOU DO SO
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TOP FIVE CARRIAGES HAVE
ONE CONCLUDING COMMENT. WHICH
IS TO THANK ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US. AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. SO
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. FIVE AND
CERTAINLY- YOUR PATIENCE
EVERYONE SO TODAY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES IS NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.